Kellogs Cornflakes werden als
vollwertiges Frühstück beworben dabei
ist der gesunde Kern gar nicht mehr im
Korn und hier stecken alle wertvollen
Vitamine und Mineralien drin
nur das hier
landet nicht im Cornflake stattdessen
streckt die Industrie sie mit
künstlichen Nährstoffen und Fakten
die Brühe schmeckt original nach
Cornflakes da war aber noch überhaupt
kein Mais drin
[Musik]
die guten alten Cornflakes in der
Werbung sagt man einen vollwertiges
Frühstück glauben Sie wirklich dass das
hier ein vollwertiges Frühstück ist dann
passen sie jetzt mal auf
der Kellogs Trick
[Musik]
Sebastian legen nimmt Cornflakes genauer
unter die Lupe zunächst wie
unterscheidet sich das Markenprodukt von
den günstigen Alternativen
ich weiß gar nicht mehr weil ich das
letzte Mal Cornflakes gegessen habe
für das sieht aus wie Cornflakes wie ich
sie kenne
die schmecken auch so knusprig
[Musik]
die schmecken gut und die sind am besten
getoastet die sind richtig
und jetzt das Original vom Erfinder im
self meist erstmal Zucker und Salz
schmecken die jetzt anders alle Produkte
bestehen aus den gleichen Zutaten
[Musik]
großen Unterschied kann ich da nicht
erkennen beim Preis sind die
Unterschiede beträchtlich Kellogs ist
etwa doppelt so teuer wie die NoName
Produkte von Aldi oder Lidl
ich zeige Ihnen jetzt wie man ein
Maiskorn vorbereiten muss bevor es ein
Cornflake wird
[Musik]
hier in Maiskorn wenn ich hier drauf
drücke dann kommt das hier raus das ist
der Keimling und hier stecken alle
wertvollen Vitamine und Mineralien
drinne nur das hier
landet nicht im Cornflake also man nehme
das Maiskorn man drückt in der Mitte
diesen kleinen Keimling raus
man selbst in den Mund füllt die super
fit und vital und daraus wird der
Cornflakes
maiskeime stecken voller gesunder
Inhaltsstoffe Vitamin E ungesättigten
Fettsäuren und Mineralien aus ihnen wird
maiskeimöl gewonnen
für Cornflakes nutzt die
Lebensmittelindustrie die übrig
gebliebenen Körner ohne Keim und ohne
all die gesunden Inhaltsstoffe die
Körner werden gekocht damit die auch
vernünftig schmecken stabil sind und die
richtige Farbe erhalten müssen wir das
Wasser ein bisschen pimpen
Zucker natürlich nicht zu viel weil die
schmecken ja nicht wirklich süß das Salz
ist genauso wichtig weil aktiviert das
Eiweiß und beim Pressvorgang bleibt das
Produkt wunderbar stabil
erstmals ganz beliebtes Färbemittel die
sollen ja schön goldig werden deswegen
machen wir mal eins zwei
[Applaus]
drei Löffel rein dieser sieht aus Zucker
Salz und Gerstenmalz ist das Cornflakes
das schmeckt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Brühe schmeckt original Cornflakes
da war aber noch überhaupt kein Mais
drin man bringen ihn mir kurz zum
Packung Flex
[Musik]
kleine Schlawiner
ja so viel Gerstenmalz in die Cornflakes
die schmecken voll danach
zwei Jahre lang geblendet Sebastian lege
muss den Mais nun weich kochen
erfunden wurde die Rezeptur vor über 100
Jahren in den USA
1894 kam der Arzt Harvey Kellog auf die
Idee geröstete Getreideflocken als
Schonkost in seinem Sanatorium
anzubieten
ursprünglich ganz bewusst ohne
zugesetzten Zucker gewürzt nur mit etwas
Salz eine medizinische Nahrung für
magenkranke
der jüngere Bruder Will Kellog wittert
ein Geschäft er schwenkt um von Getreide
auf Mais und setzt den Flocken Zucker zu
plötzlich schmecken die Flocken gut die
Kellogs company expandiert weltweit
1961 auch nach Deutschland
Kellogs Cornflakes Sonnenschein auf
jeden
Tisch gekocht lassen sich die Maiskörner
gut weiterverarbeiten durch Gerstenmalz
und Zucker bekommen sie Geschmack und
süße zu 84% bestehen Cornflakes aus
Kohlenhydraten
in der Cornflakes Produktion werden die
Gewalt das heißt das sind metallweizen
die werden von innen beheizt und dann
laufen wir einfach nur dadurch und dann
sind sie auch schon in der Packung
Sebastian lege hat keine Walzen zum
rösten er improvisiert mit einer
t-shirt-presse
[Musik]
hey hey hey hey
yeah yeah
na ja das ist eher die XXL Variante aber
sie lassen sich jetzt wunderbar lösen
und das sind hier meine Cornflakes die
sind schon mal richtig gut die Flakes
haben in etwa die richtige Form
flachgepresst müssen Sie jetzt noch
geröstet werden
[Musik]
so da ist sie meine automatische
Cornflakes rösstraße
in weniger als einer Minute verwandelt
der Durchlaufofen die Weichen Maisfladen
in knusprige Cornflakes die Knistern
schon ist eigentlich ein gutes Zeichen
ist wie so eine Kruste vom
Schweinebraten die knistert ja auch so
[Musik]
mega Ergebnis das Ergebnis ist gut
gelungen
[Applaus]
sie schmecken wie die ursprünglichen
Cornflakes
[Musik]
finde die schmecken total langweilig
mit Tiger Toni kommen 1952 die Frosties
auf den Markt die einstige Schonkost hat
eine extra zuckerhülle Kinder lieben sie
Kellogs hat zum zweiten Mal Zucker als
wunderbare eingesetzt und wird endgültig
zum Weltkonzern das Sortiment wächst die
Flex werden nach und nach auch aus
anderen Getreidesorten wie Reis
hergestellt und alle sind sie zuckersüß
heute bestehen Frosties zu 37% aus
Zucker ins Max stecken 34% Zucker und
den crunchy nuts süßen Cornflakes mit
erdnussstückchen 35%
. das war meine lieblings Kind
Kellogs stellt in seiner Werbung die
wertvollen Vitamine heraus
wir ziehen Eisen Vitamin B6
Folsäure Vitamin D Vitamin B12 ja junge
junge junge Junge die ursprünglichen
Cornflakes enthalten nach der
Herstellung kaum noch Vitamine
Kellogs setzt den fertigen Produkten
Vitamine zu die sind industriell
hergestellt
und jetzt die wertvollen Vitamine
Vitamin B6 Vitamin B1
Folsäure Vitamin B12 ihr ziehen und ganz
wichtig Eisen
dass die sich alles einfallen lassen
oder
Vitamin B2
fertig
Sebastian lege mischt die Zutaten in den
Zuckersirup der sorgt für den süßen
Glanz und klebt die Vitamine an
bisschen Melasse für die Farbe und schon
haben wir visuell mal ein bisschen Honig
gemacht ja Honig ist ja auch drinne
reicht und jetzt machen wir mal aus
Kornflakes mit einer Gartenspritze
sprüht Sebastian lege die mit Vitaminen
angereicherte Zuckerlösung auf die
Cornflakes das gibt Crunch und Glanz
und jetzt noch ein Hauch Erdnüsse
mit erdnussstückchen
Schonkost ist wenig geblieben
die extra Hand Erdnüsse die haben es
gebracht
Kellogs setzt bei Tresor und crunchy Nut
einen ganzen Mix an Vitaminen zu das
lenkt vom Zucker ab und lässt die
Produkte gesünder erscheinen weil
Vitaminen und Mineralstoffen ist es oft
so dass ich sie im natürlichen Verbund
besser aufnehmen kann und gleichzeitig
kommen sie dann auch zusammen mit
sekundären Pflanzenstoffen und die
werden dem Produkt hinterher nicht mehr
zugesetzt das heißt ein natürliches
Produkt mit den natürlich vorkommenden
Vitaminen Mineralstoffen und sekundären
Pflanzenstoffen ist in der Regel besser
als mit künstlichen Zusätzen